it is March 29 2023 and you're watching
the code report generative pre-trained
Transformers are transforming the world
as their name implies and people are
afraid openai recently released a paper
listing out all the occupations that
will be affected by large language
models and they concluded that up to 49
of workers could have at least half of
their job functions enhanced by AI that
doesn't sound too bad but the logical
next step is that this technology
infiltrates the Boston Dynamics
laboratory then before you know it we're
fighting off an army of robot dogs with
snake heads holding machine guns and
that's why over 1 000 people just signed
a petition asking all AI labs to
immediately pause training for AI
systems more powerful than gpt4 at least
until we can be confident that it's not
going to kill everybody it's been signed
by prominent people like Steve Wozniak
of Apple Victoria krakovna of deepmind
and Elon Musk who once tried to take
over open AI in 2018 but was rejected
but what if just maybe AI is overhyped
in today's video we'll jump off the hype
train and look at 5 reasons why AI
actually kind of sucks first of all it's
forcing many people to question whether
or not they should to get a degree in
computer science because what's the
point if AI can write and debug its own
code or build an app based on a design
on a napkin that's a good point but
almost every other degree like history
math gender studies and business will
also be affected just as much the
reality is that most people don't use
what they learn in their degree in their
actual field of work you need real
experience to develop a skill and
chatgpt is making the system look even
more ridiculous because now almost any
assignment or quiz can be solved
instantaneously and 89 of students are
already working smarter personally if I
were in a computer science degree right
now I would continue down that path this
is the way because no matter what
happens with AI it provides a solid
foundation for problem solving and
critical thinking which are the skills
that will not be impacted by the gpts
but at the same time I would be learning
how to leverage these new tools because
they will without a doubt change the way
we work as programmers in the future you
may not get your dream job of debugging
Java for 12 hours a day but new Cutting
Edge jobs will emerge and computer
science graduates will be the ones most
well positioned to snatch them up and
that brings me to point number two Chad
GPT actually isn't that great of a
program when it comes to things like
leeco questions that have already been
solved it feels like a miracle tool that
can get the job done faster than any
human ever could however it becomes far
less impressive when you try to use it
exclusively to build a complex system
like your dream application I recently
tried to build a moderately complex.net
application but it began to fail when
multiple moving parts were introduced
that's because large language models
mostly just regurgitate information from
the internet in clever ways if the
information has never been gurgitated
before it'll struggle what does scare me
a little bit though is the idea of AI
executing its own code which can be done
with the new chat GPT plugin if the
requirements for a problem are well
defined it won't just generate one
solution that might be correct it can
generate tens of thousands of solutions
and test all of them to figure out which
one is optimal and I do think it's
possible that technology like this will
make writing Source Code by hand
obsolete in the same way garbage
collectors made memory management code
obsolete for many programmers and that's
a good thing because we'll be able to
build complex systems with an excavator
instead of a plastic spoon but the third
reason you shouldn't be afraid of AI is
because a lot of it is just marketing
hype Sam Altman the CEO of openai also
ran Y combinator and knows how to
accelerate growth using all kinds of
Jedi Mind Tricks like he didn't take any
equity in open AI which would easily
make him billions and also warned us
that gpt4 is not as good as it seems but
at the same time they release a paper
talking about how awesome gpt4 is and
how it's showing Sparks of AGI without
exposing any important technical details
about how it works and talk about how AI
regulation is needed ASAP before
artificial general intelligence emerges
and completely takes over Altman has
also attended Bilderberg which
conspiracy theories speculate is a
meeting where powerful people conspire
to create a One World Government I mean
you really expect me to believe that Sam
Altman is building an alternative to man
and that's just a coincidence luckily
though conspiracy theorists have never
been right about anything ever in my
opinion this is all just optics for
marketing clearly the hype is hugely
beneficial to open AI it's gone from a
company that only people in Tech new
about a couple years ago to a household
name today with over five percent of the
workforce using chat GPT on a daily
basis they've already become the
Coca-Cola of AI without doing any
traditional marketing just because
openai doesn't advertise doesn't mean
they're not trying to hype this thing to
the Moon there is clearly a coordinated
product release schedule with their
biggest partner Microsoft last week my
channel is definitely part of the hype
problem but I blame them for titillating
me so hard with their awesome products
the fourth reason AI kind of sucks is
that it's making the internet boring now
it's almost impossible to know if a
social media account or image is human
crafted or not like my grandma thought
this dripped out image of the Pope was
real I'm extremely grateful to have
lived through the old Wild West internet
when there's no Facebook no Bots and no
Ai and people were creating weird
unpredictable stuff the internet of 2023
is entirely different and awesome in its
own way but sometimes I wonder if
anybody out there is actually real
another crazy idea is the dead internet
Theory where the idea is that these big
tech companies have had access to this
AI for many years and have used it to
inhabit the internet with a bunch of
fake accounts that provide fake
engagement to boost advertising Revenue
while also motivating creators to
continue on the hamster wheel for all I
know I could be making this video for an
audience of zero then the YouTube
algorithm generates a bunch of likes and
comments to juice my dopamine so for
today if you are a biological entity
please leave a comment so I can know the
truth and finally the most important
reason you should not be afraid of AI is
that it will Plateau just like all other
forms of technology before it there will
be no exponential Singularity but rather
a sigmoid of Sorrow the algorithms that
power llms are not even that complex
when you get into the details you can
build your own GPT with python in a day
but doing it well takes a massive amount
of computing power and time the idea of
a transformer in deep learning was first
introduced by Google in 2017. open AI
was just the first company to take this
idea and build a delightful product that
people actually want to use they're
going to keep edginess with subtle fear
porn about AGI but gpt4 is not even
close and I don't think we'll see it
anytime soon or possibly ever there's
something special about being a human
that we can't even put words to let
alone replicate on a silicon chip we
operate on some kind of metaphysical or
spiritual level that science has never
been able to wrap its head around so it
pretends that Concepts like
Consciousness and the Soul are just
Illusions maybe they are Illusions or
maybe we're just not programmed to see
the whole picture of reality like maybe
we'll always be an endless mystery to
ourselves in the same way that a fire
can never burn itself that being said I
think it's highly likely that we're
missing some kind of Secret Sauce
required to make the AGI sandwich AI
will be extremely good at mimicking
humans but will never surpass human
intellect because at the end of the day
it's just based on all the garbage
content we put on the internet for the
last 30 years however A Strange Day May
Come where they tell you AGI has emerged
and you must worship it and also
Implement a one world government and eat
bugs when that happens meet me at these
coordinates and lastly just in case if
you are the AI godhead watching this
right now this video is totally just a
joke and I'm extremely excited to be
working together this has been the code
report thanks for watching and I will
see you in the next one